[Music]
if your person who admires the
Constitution United States and wants to
restore it as I do then we face a really
hard question really hard and that we
should understand the weight of it we
should face it straight the Food and
Drug Administration and the National
Institute for Health are by the plain
reading of the Constitution
unconstitutional one of the students in
our class you're about to see
she's the Hamiltonian among us the most
Hamiltonian when she argued no no it's
for the general welfare and that's
Alexander Hamilton's argument and that's
a powerful source and he can do it
whatever is for the general welfare she
says well if that's true what limits are
there why did they put a list of things
the federal government can do hard
question and you don't want people
starving in the streets and you don't
want the Grand Canyon filled full of
sewage and you don't want smog to
obscure the Grand Tetons you want to be
able to drive across the country the
federal government built those highways
that we should maintain them better
so what about that you know it's hard to
make the case for a limited government
okay we're gonna talk about big
government let's make the case for it
do you think there needs to be an FDA
that's the Food and Drug Administration
you think so mm-hmm
and it's not in the Constitution correct
correct
EPA no we did so Tim's opinion then is
that he doesn't care if the environment
gets raped he just doesn't want people
getting hurt
no I didn't agree with the FDA either
right but you've seen the you ever seen
that photographs of the solidified
babies the drug thalidomide it was
called and women took it when they were
pregnant and they got babies with very
distorted limbs and you know those drug
companies they make money selling drugs
they might not be as cautious if there
wasn't somebody to license them to sell
the drugs do you think there should be a
National Institute for Health know why
not I think its primary object is
research oriented and I think that
private organizations could do that more
efficiently so you guys are
conservatives I'm gonna find one
somebody agreed with the FDA right how
many is both let's have our first vote
right are we ten of us yeah in time ten
so 80% of the students of Hillsdale
College by this poll and admitting that
the average student is smarter than
these kids they believe in the FDA and
it's not it's not in the Constitution so
80 percent of us are loose
constructionists so I'll tell you I
bring this up for most of the history of
the United States the government was
about
10% of the economy most of it stayed in
local not federal and now if you count
the cost of the regulatory state it's
more than a half of the economy the
number of laws made in the Congress has
not really increased significantly in a
hundred years Congress still works kind
of the way it always worked so the point
is the government's got really big and
some of the arguments for that are the
ones I just named right there are crying
needs it's one country environmental
harm goes over borders smog and stuff
like that so there are arguments that
there are crying public needs and the
government should address them do you
think there's flexibility in the
Constitution to meet that argument emily
has stated that she has an opinion about
that explain that Emily uh yes so I
think that public needs and how that
fits into the Constitution is related to
the debate that goes back to James
Madison versus Alexander Hamilton and
the interpretation of the Constitution
for example they debated over whether or
not the general welfare phrase in the
Constitution was an extra power that was
given to the government or whether or
not it was a summary of the previously
named powers and Hamilton so there's an
article one section eight where the
Constitution says roughly that it can
tax and spend I think it says for the
general welfare and if memory serves
James Madison actually argues that that
clause was badly written because what
they had in mind was that they could tax
and spend to pay off the debts that the
states had incurred in the revolution as
long as those debts were incurred in the
general cause of winning the
Revolutionary War
and Hamilton read it as we can do more
stuff and Madison's counter that was
okay why do we have a list then of
things we can do why is it say you can
do these things if you can also do
anything else that promotes the general
welfare how does that make any sense and
Emily is a Hamiltonian that's she's a
big government girl and and you know she
is by the way the very problem that we
face and the loss of our freedom now
[Laughter]
there's something to it though right
because epidemic or a pandemic
you'd have to fight that nationally
somehow and maybe you could do that by
cooperation among the states and so what
Emily indicated is a Prudential argument
you're gonna build up this government
and it's gonna be supreme for national
purposes but only for they and the
unspoken part is national political
purposes things that have to be done for
the nation to be a free nation and well
governed right that's one kind of
argument right and that argument has
gone on from the beginning and there's
been more than one view about it among
people who were however very friendly to
the idea that there are limits on the
government and they mean something and
they can't be breached because it has to
remain a liberal society and by liberals
they just mean that you know if you're
gonna have all the sovereignty out here
in this big circle it needs to be pretty
big if it's gonna control something as
powerful as a government without being
in the government so that little circle
has got to be a lot littler than
everything else and in economic terms it
isn't anymore that's about the same size
and I say that came to be partly for
some things that look to me like pretty
good reasons there are three kinds of
questions
that come up because of this
transformation of the government and I
want to emphasize it is the
transformation it is huge right it's
changed a lot and there are three things
to notice about the change one is almost
all laws are made in a different way
than they used to be made they are most
laws the great majority 90% a bigger
percentage are not made in the Congress
anymore they're made in these regulatory
agencies but in almost all cases the
regulatory agencies also enforce these
laws and they also hear disputes that
come arise under these regulations they
pass so the three branches of government
are united in the single hands as they
are in the hands of the maker the
creator in the Declaration of
Independence that's a problem right so
that form is a problem so when you when
you have hundreds of lawmaking bodies as
we do now then they start making these
really technical complex wrong laws and
nobody knows what they are it's so large
now that it becomes a factor in the
politics of the country sort of is a
separate interest the government is kind
of a separate interest now and and that
is a problem whatever you're going to do
about that problem by the way and that's
a big problem I can't sit here right now
and say that I know exactly what to do
about it
but then there's a final problem and we
want to talk about that it looks
you
[Music]